voici mental
yvan attal deux cent mille entrées
france en cinq jours c'est énorme
peut-être me rends pas compte et énorme
de cent mille entrées ma femme est une
actrice donc le film que vous avez
réalisé où vous jouez avec votre femme
l'actrice charlotte gainsbourg est un
succès et ça se fête
je vous demande de vous arrêter bien
yvan bravo donc 200 milles en 37 jours
c'est énorme
alors dans ce film est aussi terrance
tarp noémie lvovsky laurent bateau
lionel abelanski et ludivine sagnier
voilà alors je fais tout là ici toute
façon c'est ça qui est génial on a juste
et c'est bien la juge a fait comme ça
comme les chiens l'arrière des voitures
fait comme ça voilà c'est ça qui est
génial
donc c'est une comédie populaire de
qualité c'est comme ça qu'on appelle ça
élégante on y est les grands avec du
style absolument c'est difficile ce
genre de film et c'est rare donc c'est
d'autant mieux pour vous parce que y'en
a pas souvent et puis surtout je dirais
pour un flemmard comme mots parce que
vous êtes un sacré costard quand même
nom yvan non c'est vrai c'était la
première fois que j'avais autant de
travail de ma vie je me suis découvert d
une énergie dingue c'est encore plus dur
quand on est paresseux mais oui parce
que les mecs bossent heures ils ont pas
de mérite
moi je me suis levé pour la première
fois de ma vie je me suis couché tard à
la fin de ma vie quand je devais me
lever tôt le matin c'était un boulot
j'ai sous-estimé
quand on est acteur on sous-estiment le
boulot que c'est un metteur en scène
vraiment c'est ce qui m'a surpris
pourtant ça faisait dix ans que je
faisais du cinéma et vraiment je
m'attendais pas à cette somme de travail
vous étiez les deux en plus acteurs
réalisateurs de mary margaret ameziane
principal ça fait beaucoup quand même
on est non seulement flemmards mais
hypocondriaque en plus un très
hypothétique ça c'est fou parce que par
exemple quand il fait des analyses sur
les radios sur les analyses il les fait
deux fois ce qui ce dit si des fois il
ya un labo qui se trompent l'autre
vérité ce qui est marrant en revanche
c'est que pendant le film j'ai eu aucune
crise de rien n'est pas été malade etc
mais dès que je me suis arrêté de
tourner ça a commencé le cancer du
cerveau humain
effectivement je vais faire des scanners
quand je suis un scanner géant j'en fais
deux tranches et là je me suis mis à
lire m
ah oui depuis le france bien mais ça
prend du temps d'être malade tout le
temps comme ça il faut aller voir les
toubibs est ou non mais oui oui ça prend
une surtout quand on les voit en double
ouais
alors je vais faire le pitch vous voulez
non je veux bien dans le pitch est
simple 1 c'est yvan qui est reporter
sportif donc il n'est pas acteur c'est
très important parce que c'est ça
explique beaucoup de choses dans le film
si vous allaitez acteurs soient pas été
bien c'est juste que je voulais pas
laisser les spectateurs à la ramasse son
compte ce qu'on raconte le fait qu'ils
soient par ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît pas vraiment ce métier dont il
ya à peu près comme tous les spectateurs
il pénètre dans ce métier comme al ahram
le personnage haye est jaloux ouais voir
parano way est une zone allemand moi je
le trouve totalement lucide 1 qu'il a
raison sa femme se fait un mec au cinéma
les accords de faux mais elle se fait
quand même tripoter on les voit paré
pour vous cela alors un jour donc il
tombe sur un fan un peu lourdaud qui lui
prend la tête en voulant savoir ce qui
se passe vraiment au cinéma qui veut
dire enfin de la femme
voilà quoi quand et la peau avec un mec
quand il se roule une pelle c'est pour
de vrai catalan ils s'embrassaient pour
de vrai ouais c'est parce que moi je lui
explique que c'est pour de faux
ouais il lui s'obstine en me disant
ouais bon moi même j'ai eu la gaule en
regardant sa femme à l'écran hier donc
imagine l'acteur est donc là yvan vous
vous péter les plombs et d'autant plus
que charlotte pas retourner à londres
avec terrine stop pendant longtemps que
je veux dire c'est un tournage à
l'étranger elle revient pas tous les
soirs et ses bas quand on tourne quand
sa femme et à l'étranger on l'a pas sous
la main donc on a des angoisses quand on
a ce genre de conversation avec ce type
au café et qu'on commence à avoir le le
ver dans la pomme c'est encore plus
angoissant avant sa femme et l'étranger
qui tourne avec un acteur charismatique
séduisant qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend
l'eurostar et on va la retrouver tout de
suite sur les clash